[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
yeah
welcome what's up guys hello this is a
very unique stream it's a little bit
risque in that uh we are relying on a
Star Wars trailer to be released to what
we think is going to be 9:30 Pacific uh
based on the St
celebration stream that's going on right
now they uh they have their panel and I
don't know every year they do it and at
the end they show something on uh the
upcoming Star Wars movies so we're we're
putting all our cards in the bucket if
yeah I love that say if you know what I
mean classic Star Wars phrase classic
Star Wars uh so yeah uh 9:30 is when
we're expecting this trailer to drop in
the meantime I am Rob hanry and this is
josha and this is Peter Brown two my
great buds uh and we're going to play
some Star Wars games in the meantime not
just any Star Wars games not just any
Star Wars games uh we're going back to
the N64 going play some Pod racer play
Rogue Squadron my personal favorite
Rebel Assault 2 on PC Rebel Assault 2 on
PC and that is a very very entertaining
game uh for its uh FMV which is really
well produced oh just the top notch I
think topnotch well let's dive right
into it we got Pod racer right here this
game is so legit uh not the Dreamcast
version not the PC version unfortunately
N64 N64 we had a lot of uh Josh you're
going for it we had a lot of fun H
hooking this 64 up um yeah this game is
really you know for its time it was
freaking awesome uh what we going to do
time
attack uh this game is this game is
tough for one thing but I played the
hell out of it like 100% this thing look
at that pit
Droid uh
rjb go rjb whose game is this this is
actually well what's funny is got it's
got stickers on it that says property of
Blockbuster so so nobody owns it now no
one owns it SSS is dumb do this
one uh un did that pick the character I
had this 100% this is not my original
game game I can't couldn't find it yeah
you get to pick the charact look at that
weirdo right there does it have sabba no
it doesn't so that's the bust and it
also doesn't have like uh the original
Alon Elon Musk Elon Musk the names I
feel like I call these guys in my own
head dud
bolt look at these fre that guy like a
clown W
[Laughter]
sausage oh man this game's good uh
yeah pick you know why you why don't you
pick the man himself yeah why not I
don't want the guy at the max cooling I
like this guy cuz his name
slide uh all right I think we got audio
on this game oh yeah need it there is
need it's working it's working yeah yeah
that's right track
favorite when this came out it was
actually like pretty cool all the stuff
you could do to the vehicles like buying
pit droids yeah you could upgrade Parts
yeah does this game use the ram cart you
know that red thing you slot oh yeah the
uh the uh what expansion yeah yeah or no
what was it even called the expansion
pack P yeah yeah and we are uh also
looking at chat we're looking at you
guys uh YouTube and twitch um I also was
hoping we could
um what are the buttons a go uh oh you
like let go and boost there's some and I
was looking online to see if I could get
I
could if I could like unlock the other
tracks and race uh drivers but the only
cheat code is like a debug one that to
my knowledge all it does is just put
numbers on all the [__] players nice
that's it cheat code isn't there a way
to like rotate
sideways oh you have yeah yeah uh the uh
the left and right C you have to use the
C button while holding a
yeah but again uh we're looking at chat
if you guys like I was hoping we could
maybe start some conversation on you
know what do you guys think is going to
be the first shot in the new
trailer nailed
it uh okay like aside from like a wide
shot of outer
space yeah do you think that would been
in the trailer or the
movie I'm thinking a
closeup of oh my God someone seriously
saying the trailer is out guys no no
someone's been trolling okay good um I
think it'll I think it'll actually go
straight from the end of seven and it'll
be them on that M yeah that's a good
call
yeah the passing of the torch
maybe it's hard to say what'll be in the
trailer but what do you guys think will
be in the movie boy cuz I watched
episode 7 and I think one thing that
this movie needs to have is like more
fin stuff cuz like he ends seven in in
pretty much like a medical coma mhm and
then like he really has no character Arc
beginning here it's like he escaped he's
a good guy now I see what they can do
with Ray and uh like kylo Ren but I
don't see Finn having much of a story
here unless they start one here we go he
needs some sort of he needs a bigger
conflict around him I me I know there is
the his inherent conflict being a a turn
Coke but um but it's kind of over right
yeah precisely right like so that
defines part of his character but even
then then the rest of the movie he was
kind of a goofball for the most part
yeah um like he doesn't seem like he has
much at stake he's not a natural at
anything he's not like an amazing pilot
or something you got PO for that he's a
janitor oh I'll show you how to get that
stain
out guys I I can take care of this
toilet clock give
second Rebel need all Luke falls in love
with Ray all right that would be
uh I mean yeah obviously the big mystery
is if he's the dad or not but right it's
that really won't change all that much
really it's okay or isn't but is he
going to like die I kind of feel like
the idea that Han might be her dead also
is not really a thing given that like
his death has kind of been well
addressed by the the last movie so like
to they would have to revisit that to
like make the impact of you know if he
was her father like all more
important that would seem that would
seem almost like a step backwards in
terms of the
story well and like it would be weird
because they already have a kid right
it'd be weird to have like another twin
split at birthing yeah but but I mean if
you look at the first movie how much it
mimicked A New Hope in terms of so many
you know pacing things and uh I'm just
saying I wouldn't put it past him but I
think it would be silly I think uh this
movie will be like the
twists cuz the first one is like let's
remake kind of The Originals and this
one's where they do twists and one of
those is probably like yeah Luke's
probably not her dad he's just some guy
maybe Obi-Wan is there's like rumors
there's an Obi-Wan movie that'll be
announced this weekend oh right I'm not
sure if that'll actually happen but
maybe that'll if like there is some uh
you know lineage there and then they
have this movie where they can explore a
relationship or something I don't know
although it's not like she could be you
know his daughter she'd have to be like
a grandkid
yeah I saw on the subreddit Star Wars
leaks that someone was saying that um
it's rumored that they're going to show
footage of the new Han Solo movie which
I don't even know if that's been
confirmed that they were shooting it I
didn't even know yeah I didn't even know
they were shooting that already I think
that's pretty I mean they might have
gotten like a couple shots I mean they
only finished casting like a handful of
months ago right right yeah that doesn't
make sense and there was also a recent
rumor on that uh that website about like
here's a shooting location so clearly
they're pretty
[Laughter]
early I like this like I like this guy's
like pod if that's what you would call
it it's just like a freaking Rudder
yeah whoa oh man flashbacks who did all
this graffiti am I going the wrong
way look like you're did I just get
uh no you're good you're good yeah
you're still in the running yeah this
guy died in the movie he got shot by a
uh sand
person and this thing made a funny noise
when it
spun so this is
before this is a prequel this is a
prequel to the prequel this is the
earliest thing in the lore
officially but Anakin can never finish a
race Anakin just just Planet hopping
I'll never get off this sand
Planet the casting for the Han Solo
movie is funny cuz it's like Woody
harelson as like a mentor yeah so weird
like the exact role he did from uh
Hunger Games too right oh right so it's
it's got to be something similar he's
like the older Smuggler he teaches Han
Solo the ropes oh that's right this is
now
like I stretches this is this
LAX damn good one
[Laughter]
dude H that was off the top of my head
man uh trailer supposed to arrive at the
end of the panel which just started so
yeah just to clarify uh what we're
trying to do here if you're just joining
us is uh we're we're going to mess
around with some old Star Wars games and
then uh at 9:30ish is when we expect the
panel will end and they'll show
hopefully we're really winging it here
hopefully they'll show the first Last
Jedi trailer and we'll uh watch it and
then we'll comb through it and uh you
know talk about frame by frame what we
think is going one frame at a time one
frame at a time we're going to study it
if they don't show it we'll just end the
stream 9:30 and if I'll talk to you guys
later God if they don't show it I swear
I think I'll just be fired
oh um what time do we got right now it's
uh 8:10 okay looks like Kathleen Kennedy
is just got introduced on the panel
Kathleen K Kennedy
awesome I think that's her name yeah it
is and then you got uh is it re it's
Ryan Ryan it's Ryan it's definitely Ryan
Johnson and then um yeah I would imagine
cast of the movie would come out do you
think the uh Chrome Trooper is going to
make a big appearance in this movie I
hope so you and you read the uh what
would you call it like the uh the book
version of the actual movie and like
Captain fasma had like much or not much
bigger role but had a couple of like I
think imperative scenes like in her kind
of narrative more or less like um I
forget still didn't like not much but
like there was there was more more
reason to why she gave the death or Star
Killer plans or no sorry she turn down
the shield yeah there's more reason to
why she did that like chewy like more or
less like tortur her yeah I think he the
movie made it seem like kind of just
like all right I guess I'll do it right
I think the the idea is like it doesn't
matter
because cuz nothing matters it doesn't
matter cuz uh my troops will be here and
stop you anyways but still pretty crazy
for the captain to just be like yeah
sure I don't want to be shot so I'll
just shut the whole thing down but
there's this whole bit about like her
armor right and it's
like something something about chewy
like grabbing her helmet she's like you
can't like break this helmet it's made
out of some I don't know something and
then she was like dude check this out he
starts squeezing her
helmet so I actually heard I hope I'm
not making this up I feel like I read
you've crashed there before haven't you
no one of the uh you know visual novel
books or whatever her like Chrome metal
is made from the ruins
of like Palpatine ship from the prequels
those like nibo ones yeah right Chrome
she just dug up some of that Chrome but
it's a pretty cool idea they had back
then like dude Chrome ships can't see us
if we're a
mirror I love
it oh what am I doing that's what that's
why that's why now this is
Padre it's
working dude you are in last place says
someone
yep it's
tough I'm playing on the
hardest difficulty someone says this is
the
trailer that's a pod racing in Last Jedi
um should we switch sh sure yeah cuz we
got to save a lot of time for Rebel
assault I think we should yeah we I was
playing a little bit of Rebel assault
that game is a masterpiece we really
want to dive into it um yeah thank you
for cutting away here we go all right
blow on the cartridge let's oh don't do
that I used to do
this oh my
God the thing was is you you whatever
your mess method was whenever you you
did it and then it turned on and it
worked you're like told you like damn
that's a good
method people can see the panel now for
at least a few seconds so it's it's
happening this is what you're missing
this is what you're
missing but who needs that we're playing
Star Wars Rogue Squadron Peter you want
to be sure the first so was this the
game that the expansion pack came out
for first I had that for Perfect Dark I
don't know what it but that game was
crippled without it
yeah Factor five remember them yeah they
went on to make a couple sequels for
this on GameCube that are just awesome
yeah that's where I never I never yeah
the bwing had a bwing oh my God look at
that body start that start
menu let's see how far I gotten
this tit Josh tit oh man
ti
What just nodding your head after you
like typed in the last T like yeah this
is good oh my God not
very is there any reason can we give you
the benefit of the doubt for some kind
of
acronym wow totally into
Tatooine that's my gang's name uh yeah
if you're just joining us we're going to
play some Rogue Squadron currently get
banned on Twitch we're gonna
uh we're going to mess around with uh
some Star Wars games until what we think
the trailer uh will be released at 9:30
a.m. Pacific oh damn we should enter the
codes and get like the million Falcon
and the Cadillac can you get the tie
advanced in this one uh or is that a
GameCube thing no the tie advance or TIE
Interceptor yeah interceptor yeah you
can do this one you know was the
craziest too the V
WIS the craziest was
uh when this game came out which was
which was before the prequel episode one
mhm they had the code in it for the nabo
star fighter which is just like I think
one of the most like impressive chat
codes of all time like what like they
they knew about that so early on and
then release the code when that came out
like or however they did it like that's
so cool yeah and it never got like
cracked or I don't know figured out
before
[Music]
right are we watching this or are we
going to the game you're you're
[Music]
skipping is before uh four and five at
pts this is there's an imperial storage
base nearby it's an inventory whe system
Wheels like if that was your personal
transport your commute would take
forever good call and his ground troop
should find plenty of supplies in the
base as long as we can knock out the
shield generator it's located at the end
of a canyon Rift some this game was
really cool this told a pretty cool
story with like a TIE fighter pilot who
defected and everything mhm yeah that's
right I think one of the harder Maps was
like private Channel sir uh it's like I
think it's on like the kle asteroid and
you're like it's a
um you're you're rescuing pilots in a
train and you have to
like guard the train as it's moving
along uh that asteroid and like you
could like if they I know basically the
the like train compartments would always
like blow up it was just really hard to
defend them I just remember like you're
like running around the planet doing
other side missions while you're
defending the train yeah yeah i' tell
you to go like take out out
anti-aircraft guns or something yeah one
pretty cool thing about a game this old
was like there were a lot of variety in
the missions with like different types
of ships for different purposes like you
do like Search and
Destroy like you need an a-wing to like
search out a map and stuff right or like
the y-wing had the ion cannon that you
would use to like right not like you
know to disable disable as opposed to
destroying something and then Speeders
had the toe cables to take out ships the
uh what are they called adats adats I
like at
but to each their own takes longer it
does take
longer this frame rate perfect something
else no no no no those are good those
good the uh GameCube I have the GameCube
ones but I don't think we want to hook
up two old
consoles those were cool though they had
the like overlay that would pop down and
like give you like a battle view right
yeah they're really good looking games
too yeah if you're just joining us um we
think the trailer is coming out at 9:30
uh a.m. so that would mean we got what
maybe an hour about an hour we're hoping
it's going to
drop uh Meanwhile we're playing uh old
Star Wars games uh currently Rogue
Squadron on the 64 and then after this
is Rebel assault which is going to be
real fun ooh
uh but yeah hang tight yeah uh right now
here it's 8:20 so an hour and 10
minutes it looks like they're uh doing
some behind the scenes Cary Fisher stuff
on oh that that trailer yesterday was uh
or not trailer Jesus that um that piece
on Carrie Fisher was really great yeah I
definitely choked up that was really
nice real well done yeah I it's funny to
think like that was a pretty cool move
that they used Rebel Rebel uh the song I
did not put that together really yeah oh
right when it kicked in I was like oh
that's a pretty good move what am I uh
what am I missing here in this map sorry
to change the subject I feel like
there's someone else I'm supposed to
take out maybe if you push pause they'll
they'll tell you what you're doing
wrong missile okayy Shield generator
they're trying to get into that right
where is General maid that's right so
blow up
anything I think in general it'll be
that same thing from like Hoth where
it's the circles halfway in the
ground I think UPC or down SE is your
Photon right wait
proton oh yeah there goes there goes I
got you wait am I doing
it yeah it'll be like hidden somewhere
nearby you can uh go into Cruise mode is
it like left SE or something oh uh s
foils that
was no oh so you can change the firing
pattern of the laser by pressing left SE
uh I don't know one I'm kidding no
that's uh left left C or right C is
going to be there you go that's boost no
you changed you closed it so you go
faster less
maneuverable jar jar
snoke have you guys looked into like
those those videos and like they break
down sounds r it's it's pretty
interesting like it it kind of what I
what I will kind of agree with is it
almost seems like George Lucas had
bigger plans for jarra but because of
that just flop of a character he like
abandoned it we're
like man it's kind of neat like just how
like how these scenes are like w you
were looking at like the episode one
stuff right the episode one stuff where
he's like coincidentally doing moves and
like changing people's minds people
think or like like how is he so insanely
good at like just triple quadruple
jumps like people were like I don't I
think something part of me that though
that thinks like episode one no one
realized how like analytical people were
going to get on these movies cuz it had
been so long and then just a few
coincidences happened and now they're a
lot more careful like if you see the way
people break down Force awakens it's
like every little line is a clue for
something must be pretty hard to write
an hour and a half long movie that it's
like broken down that detailed
yeah um Charo is just a
goofball want to hear my favorite jerine
yes better than here than the planet
core God what mus
say that guy is such an
idiot you voice him so well I know I
just love that you know what it was I
think I like I think I like that or
remember that that line so well it's cuz
I didn't understand what the hell he was
saying I was like what is he saying I
like looked up the like script of it uh
all right still sense I got killed by a
light game over fine play Mission anyway
yeah do it
uh yeah if you're uh just joining us we
are playing Star Wars games until what
we think is going to be the reveal of
The Last Jedi first trailer and then
we're going to watch it you can join us
for that and then we're going to break
it down hopefully and have some uh
hopefully this is such a gamble of a
stream I know it's the most riest thing
I've ever done just planning it and
special thanks to Eric Tay and John Luke
uh in the back for helping me uh put
this together but like yeah we talking
about how how is this going to go
down and uh yeah we just kind of pieced
it together as we talked about it this
isn't uh Star Fox Daddy
sir no Barrel snoke is George Lucas's
boyfriend
says hyper rate hyper
rate uh I think someone said DJ here so
my boss's boss is in the chat what's up
I'll be into work
late by the way consider this my not
oh yeah damn that was nice D oh I
remember this level bruises yeah no
armor though no armor I'm hit I'm hit
ouch Shields are a little weak he's
already
dying Mission starts two people just die
yeah this mission is you have to just
like find the ship that's under
[Music]
attack right so you can luck upon it
right away or just just cruise this
level
forever I think eventually it's just
like okay it's
here yeah this mission is great people
are in the chat are doing uh it's cool
going back to this oh you should go
first
person uh it's not it's not
UPC uh d-pad probably or l l on N64
always those those your guys
yeah how do you guys how can you tell
that right now I I you're looking at the
radar maybe yeah oh [__] look at that
carcket
legit there's one thing that's great
about first person awing is you got so
much room look at all that room
there I can't see no it's legit keep
doing
it those are your
[Laughter]
dudes they have two
engines right everything is so have
one
uh it is 9:00 a.m. the trail what
what is it 9:00 a.m. it's 8:30 a.m.
right now I someone is saying 9: a.m. I
am chat being a little dishonest I kind
of have the panel up on my phone Daisy
Ridley's there cool um yeah again we're
thinking uh 9:30 Pacific is when this
trailer is going to drop so about around
9:28 we're going to start we're assuming
yeah it's the end of the panel they'll
just close on it then they don't have to
answer any questions about it right man
if only I can do a quick flip so yeah
exactly 1 hour for now Jesus 1 hour
wow uh up next we got Rebel Assault 2
you're going to want to hang for that
it's legitimately funny
uh as in sorry I leave your phrase it's
funny it's not made to be
funny if there's no tra at least you'll
come out of this known Rebel assault 2o
I did not know about that Peter you
played the hell of it I'm assuming when
I was a little kid yeah it was like uh
one of the only games I had on
Playstation early
on it was not good I could never beat it
oh the uh radar was showing you where
you're supposed to go but I don't know
how accurate that was should we just
switch over to Rebel assult now I feel
like an hour it's going to be good or do
you guys want to play one of these I
played some pod racing I'm not finding
much success here here let me try find
it also which buttons do that one uh
let's see yeah let's play Let's Play One
More Josh you get one death
okay it's a lot of pressure I'm
sorry this is oh yeah here we go no
problem oh you found
it uh whoops oh here we
go oh that's right those man I haven't
seen one of those like larger sized uh
Lambda Landing crafts since Rogue one
were they in Rogue one uh no but
something like it everyone gets their
own like custom one now oh my God you
are there's like government spending is
off the hood in Star War there's no like
uh there's only one stick in this so
it's kind of tough it's yeah what are
you talking about the controller is
perfect yeah I guess the land those
Landing shuttles were never in the
trilogy were they uh not the big ones
yeah so is this like the first
appearance of it like I can't remember
anything well what were they in besides
I just remember them really
well like I had the toy for the Lander
what I had that to I had that this that
huge BBH on the
panel shouldn't say that everyone's
going to go oh I'll watch that later oh
God trailer is uh hopefully in 1 hour
uh we're going to be playing some uh
games until then you know what I never
noticed uh from episode 7 that I just
thought was a little strange is like BBA
is kind of like the you know runaway
hero of the beginning everyone loves him
and then he is not in the whole like
second half of the movie at all he's
just just tumbling around the ship well
he's he's he's in he's in X-Wing right
so when they go to St killer base like
he's just not really a
character he doesn't do anything he he
didn't fix close Shields yeah maybe that
was R2 just fixing the X-Wing flyer and
and taking a a hit dying another thing
that needs to happen in uh episode 8
similar to seven is like Po needs a
story too cuz right now his story is
just like he's the best at everything
like there's no like character flaws
so if he's going to be some sort of like
hero I don't know or maybe just stays
the
best
yeah his like only backstory is like his
parents were in Return of the Jedi's
Heroes too so he learned how to Pilot an
aing as a kid and he like that's awesome
oh that's pretty
cool did did you read he had his own
comic right uh I haven't read that yet
I'm not sure if the like the trade is
out yet I was going to kind of wait till
there was a little collection
[Music]
that Battlefront 2 trailer what do you
guys think of that oh yeah I'm still not
totally sold we'll see I'm not totally
sold either and like I I
did I got hyped on it only because I
think the time period is is a cool
decision as far as a single player but
um what would sell it that's a good call
I I
think it's story for me like a single
player or just a good
plot a good single player like narrative
with like an arc some character
development is that trailer officially
out or is there still only the leaked
one just that leaked one which is I
think definitely a a trimmed down
version of whatever final trailer they
have cuz it seems like way too quick it
was 30
seconds that was probably supposed to be
like a YouTube pre-roll kind of thing
right um the like things that did say
where it seems like you're a pilot for
the Imperials sounded a lot like the
book Lost Stars which I keep telling Rob
to read but I don't know if Rob reads
I've never seen him read like even a
word I don't know L stars is really cool
it's like the best book that's come out
since they like got rid of all the old
ones uh it's about like two young kids
who kind of go to the Imperial
Academy it's super are these good guys
yeah damn are you about to finish this
Mission I think you are as long as this
thing doesn't blow up
now
oh think you're going to be good uh-oh
whoa that thing really punch it nice
good work cool nice work oh yeah all
right well let's move on to I think what
is going to be the highlight let's hope
it works it doesn't crash it's it's a
pretty ghetto thing we have here as far
as few steps to this uh transition here
right I got a bronze you got a bronze
just so everyone know your accuracy was
oh 1%
down uh oh yeah got to do this
here we're
swapping uh so yeah this is Rebel salt 2
20 Say My Name What's that
name I think we're good to go uh if you
want to switch Sean
Luke
he's good cool uh should I play first
okay we're going beginner for sure
cuz custom difficulty these games don't
so there's like a few different types of
like gameplay like within here and none
of them really control very well this is
not a well-made game it's not now listen
to this CU we thought this was like this
has to be in game but if you know I have
not unlocked chapter8 if I click
it listen to that noise wow legit so
this this game is freaking
incredible be
wings that's pretty cool maning vessel
repeat your message we read you but
you're breaking up repeat this cargo
vessel Coria
star Fighters
Alliance the
Empire talking through a
potato destroy Alliance repeat your
message
corellia look so
annoyed thank God that's over my ears
are bleeding repeat was there a shot
earlier though of them getting shot at
it was the millennium Falcon though yeah
like who I think that dude who was on
the other end of the bad
camera yeah uh again if you're just
joining us we're playing Rebel salt
2 the
renowned video game awarded 100 Stars
worldwide yeah this is
legit uh take a shot every time Rob says
that and uh we're going to I think we
got what what's we doing 45 minutes 45
minutes of this no it's like 54 minutes
54 minutes we got some other games get
get started yeah and uh we're waiting
for the trailer to drop we think it's
going to be 9:30 we technically we
technically have other games but yeah
we're really hoping this one does well
last the whole time it will I mean I
think this game can go almost two
hours I I excuse me
yes yes we just end up like youtubing um
all the cut
scenes yeah it might be that no this
is wait okay I see him
now yeah uhhuh uhhuh
yeah I'm doing kind
[Music]
good it's dude it's it's the
cutto fantastic but
oh yeah it's pretty neat this ain't bad
though oh every time you miss
you that's
weird get out of my
way it's a pretty cool effect though
does uh Mike still hate be Wings
yeah is that why he's not here and I am
and I don't even work for this company
we assigned to to travel to uh different
state for project we uh on the on the
the lobby live show we do uh Peter and I
talked about Shadow of the Empire and
here said
some kind words about the game being
sarcastic my god really upset wait what
happened he just Peter was just ragging
on the I was just basically saying
everyone remembers that game finally
right because when it came out like in
the 64s lifespan it was kind of cool at
the time it sucks today it's a bad game
it's it's irid
yeah it was
frustrating but that was when 64 came
out that was like I had that in Mario
and that's it for like six months yeah I
feel like everyone had those two and
like maybe Wave Race or something as
well oh yeah I had Wave Race actually I
played way more Wave Race than listen
this what they say now don't start
telling me any Phantom fighter Tales
jeez you farm boys will believe anything
you hear wait I've got a fix on an
emergency distress Beacon it's on a
civilian Channel it might be the this is
join us this is the episode 8 trailer
this is episode 8 trailer right
here be
Wings they're in the
movie where they come from one do Cy are
you all right r one come in can you hear
me I'm still here but I'm in bad shape I
can't hold it I'm going
down what did he
do 13
[Music]
[Applause]
H bummer that is tight though Bey Jack
is just like the cockpit just Jets out
of there I love it this is oh yeah look
at
[Laughter]
this angle of his
walk just looks like he's got probably
like one more foot of space in this
green screen Studio huh oh my game boy
is out of
[Music]
batteries sir here but sandes and Claw
you said
it you just see the layers in Photoshop
you know what I this is getting more and
more familiar I've played this
game he was stripped over the rock
careful careful yeah like
oh there's a game here this is this is
great you almost said this is legit
yep dude I've played this
game this
[Music]
gotcha cover based shooter
gotcha everyone said gears did it first
but chill yourself
[Laughter]
D why did I suck at this game as a
kid party's
[Laughter]
over how are these
guys you're such a robot you haven't
gotten either of
them I swear the one on the right fell
over
oh do
it can you imagine a real life gun
battle like this going on for this long
like what a shootout this
boring he just
never he just never
advances oh here for days all right now
it's on he
is oh God I can't this is so dumb you
take that back no it's great
okay
wow did you say you had this for
PlayStation yeah the original
PlayStation I think it was on two discs
oh my God why is my cursor like the
worst part is that I have to re find my
Crosshair every time use the force
R also watch I think if I do head shot
like they don't work hedgehogs don't do
anything
um I'm
saying do
it okay you guys want to play H they've
got you figured
out I don't have this figured out what
the hell is that in the background
deliver of new soldiers duh oh my
gosh imagine how hard this would have
been back in the day without mechanical
keyboards High DPI gaming with a
PlayStation
controller oh my god with a controller
yeah oh my God maybe that's why I'm so
bad
yeah there these
guys does anyone have a grenade does
anyone like want to change a tactic
here the moments of Silence are the
better the speedrun of this game is like
this is
[Laughter]
it oh
boy you just crash landed here right
like
pretty ballsy move to just invade this
Base by
[Music]
yourself this pillar is my life
now oh yeah that was cool God they must
have been so stoked with this game back
when they were making it just by the
look of it cuz it looks like yeah like
obviously they're cheating and they're
doing like you know like rendered CG
ship but like still this is the closest
they got to a new film back in the day I
mean this looks like a an arcade game
more than a console game or something
right you'd go out and have the pedal to
get out of cover and
shoot it probably was pretty funny
though cuz like yeah there was like no
sight of a new movie on the horizon so
for them to be able to touch Star Wars
was like the only way you could do
it oh
jump wao that was
close oh my
God Metroid on the go is that the
Millennium Falcon yeah oh there it is oh
he found it look
[Music]
up that was
easier he's just going to steal
[Music]
this you're late and he just got out of
the shower damnn it damn it damn it
which meeting room are they
in uh yeah if you just join us
we're we're uh playing Rebel salt 2
until we think the trailer uh is
dropping at 9:30 Pacific oh
no where are you
going deeper into the
what nice flying
kid
mining
tunnels
okay what s of base is this there's
going to be Tie fighters in here holy
God oh my God this is this is going to
go so horribly no also no not at all
this is how I always assumed like these
scenes would
go like when they're flying inside the
desk
start oh man the thing about this mouse
I didn't test is the sensitivity is so
high
it probably has a button on there where
you can lower it but uh I would watch
[Music]
out close
one that was
close back at it all right I got this I
got faith in you
I son whoa I can't
see
I have an urge to
tilt like sideways but I don't think I
have that option yeah oh too close they
tried pressing buttons
though I don't
I I can't see what I'm looking at oh can
you even shoot or is this all dodging
this is pure Dodge pure
skill Jesus oh my God who built this
place
[Laughter]
dude I'm so proud of
[Music]
you I'm
nervous
what
no at like first you can't tell if it's
just the cut scene to go to the next
area and then you just destroy the
Millennium do want me to pull up the
passwords just in case we want to skip
this one
yes
but you know what I'm going to do this
first
[Music]
try oh we've got some good trolls in
chat they canceled the entire
movie oh my God that makes sense it's
believable that's so dising oh that's so
ning what if they reveal that
um like Daisy Ridley is not
his in the
[Music]
trailer it's interesting in seven how
like kind of quickly and casually they
got the kylo ren is H's son out of the
way uh we need to have Rob do this after
the next mission or we should keep it a
secret uhoh okay you guys up to okay
we're done we're done with this one is
that the first mission I don't know it
it kind of just says like in
general
yes okay I'm not sure how to enter codes
cuz this is oh yeah this is
cette the rebel fighter that gu's
getting choked Sigma Squadron stands
ready awaiting your command oh there's
one there's one cut scene that very well
Admiral Engage The
Rebels uh that we found on YouTube that
was uh like legit ripped from um you
know when uh and Emperor back when Bader
puts his helmet on they like cut in a
like a random Imperial officer and has
like a completely different line of
dialogue with Vader it's really
[Laughter]
funny okay so how do I um um maybe it's
in options beginner uhhuh oh yeah yeah
okay so we do it here right there so
okay so you just type so type in l a c h
t o
n l a c c h t o
n
what I'm looking at it right there do
you have to beat a level first or no no
that doesn't make
sense oh that noise try
Bor b o r s
SK oh all right oh nice oh this that's
weird could I
have is it like maybe you have to like
click for something
first uh oh yeah okay so hover over that
and then type in l h t n l a c h t o n
intuitive yeah all right cool asid oh
this one seems
miserable oh okay now now I get
it if you're joining us we got how much
longer here we thank 40 minutes no you
keep saying it 40 minutes I just don't
you to think it's anytime soon it could
be no I don't there's no way to tell
really but 40 minutes this is the what
we think is the uh the new trailer for
Last shedi and then we're going to watch
it live and uh talk about it afterwards
do a little bit of a dissection if you
will the real fear is that they K oh
this is it watch
[Music]
this just like the movie look at
that your report Admiral son I trust the
operation is proceeding as planned yes
Lord Vader the field tests have been
completed in 12 hours a fleet will stand
ready at imar Alpha where there'll be
pois to lay waste to the
RIT then I will look forward to
witnessing our Victory make way to imar
Alpha as you
[Music]
command good
scene
meanwhile
we have recovered the mission recorders
from thean Caro vessel we can now replay
the full distress message sent from its
pilot during the attack if you'll
observe we've discovered information
that's vital to the alliance the Empire
has a hidden Mining facility in the Bel
OFA the
processing every time press gets worse
H Reb we haven't much timeing
us oh yeah placing the fleet on Red
Alert anding the stri to the ne it
Mission investigate
belar find the Imperial complex and
disable its production capacity get to
your Fighters a mission vital to the
alliance we found a
mine I just love the idea of this
production just like the sense of laying
scenes just like yeah we'll just lay it
there's no thought about anything else
just we'll just doing post guys what
about the field no no no should we light
this no no guy just give me what you
got he is this Rascal one
standing good keep information
good better be standing by
this is going
well EAS and it just wouldn't be any
fun copy that Ace we're with you oh that
was cutting it
close wow oo Cavalier so
fun oh oh my oh oh
no oh
oh I'm not really sure if you can crash
into those cuz are you really steering
like a yeah he is cuz that those arrows
are Point hey you guys having fun too
this is I got to say again this is kind
of impressive like for the time that
this came out the game from like 93 94 I
think you'd have to imagine that this
level probably took like every asteroid
had to be
individually controlled all the
targeting reticles where they go behind
probably have to be like turned off yeah
yeah I mean well none of this is 3D
though that's the thing
right what are those I don't know oh
mines probably oh yeah those ships
right this one's mine there's one cut
scene where
like where your your call sign is rookie
one and they're just saying your name
rookie one it's like God shut
up the three
[Music]
Rascals um yeah so I guess the biggest
fear would be they decide to show this
to only people in the
audience there's no way
oh no way I mean not that many people do
that this stream I find that I mean they
did that with Star Wars though they did
that with the like Vader reveal for
rogue one yeah but they know how many ey
I mean they have all these
eyes so annoying
they did that for Doom and
stuff don't scare me it's like one of
the lowest things you can do yeah I mean
well they they've announced early in the
week that like watch the stream there's
a big surprise right oh damn look at
that poster
tight should bring up the stream real
quick got a sick post reveal and we it's
gone and it's gone it's back it's gone
[Music]
it's like an homage to the episode four
first see I told you it'd be fun yeah
thanks mer I had a ball can we go
again only six flight errors that's not
bad for navigating an asteroid field
thanks we've broken through the outou of
perimeter but the party is not over yet
well don't look now but here comes the
entertainment I read a whole FL M
interceptors Direct we
ahead uh for those of you joining us
we're waiting for the reveal of Last
Jedi trailer so we hope this this is the
riskiest stream hopefully you've ever
done yeah hopefully a half hour what
it's happening right
[Music]
now
what uh so we're going to have so it
might be happening right now yeah can
you check I can check on like yoube see
if it's if it's the trailer is on
their CH uh their
Channel meanwhile I got some T Fighters
take care
of oh wait no yeah teaser 41 seconds ago
all right how how long 2 minutes 13
seconds all
right terer this is it uh if you can uh
cut out thank you very
much he going to like crash this
computer that noise all right hang tight
guys oh boy this is going to take just a
few
moments how are you guys great here we
go no one watch it without
us oh you did you download the the
YouTube one yes oh my God you're
awesome
hopefully that is the Hope
that first one the bottom
one okay right uh pull that audio
whatever I'll do it
myself
nope 2 minutes probably 30 seconds is
like just hit f for more Star Wars
subscribe to YouTube SL stars all
right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
just
breathe
now reach
out what are you
[Music]
saying
light
Darkness
[Music]
a
balance it's so much
[Music]
bigger I only know one truth
it's time for the
Jedi to
[Music]
end
damn that was pretty [__] cool that
was rad okay
so
man the Jedi to
end yeah so damn okay super cool shots
in that a really really awesome shot I
want to see that one of them
like sand racing or whatever that was
that was such like a Mad Max shot yeah
right yeah yeah dragging that stuff
behind that was so tight but I mean
definitely a lot of stuff uh going on
but like we talked about earlier like
Finn's in the coma still and the only
shot we saw of him was in some medical
thing
right I really I really like how toned
back this
was sure
like more about atmosphere than like I
mean they saved all the action stuff for
the last like 15 20 seconds right which
is great like this is this is just
introducing style right like but how
many of these shots are not going to be
in the movie though yeah remember could
be half I mean well the the directing
style is different with uh uh Ryan
Johnson right like I
think that's so sick that is so tight
it's like you we actually didn't know
for sure that Luke would even train her
so yeah they made yeah they made some is
very
clear what is that that's kylo Ren's
mask right oh oh yeah you're totally
right I mean like this could be the
thing where he like you know tries to
get rid of that idea that like okay I'll
be just like Vader and just sort of take
on his own sort of
evil I mean that back that wall panel is
very Death Star I don't know if it's
that's true but um I that wasn't like
destroyed at the end of uh seven his
lightsaber I thought was like I only
noticed it the last time I watched it
his uh lightsaber gets destroyed so this
whole thing like this with the sorry I'm
getting used to this control the
documents like the Jedi Temple the Jedi
Bible yeah
right the Jedi instruction manual should
we watch the trailer just one more time
before we do this I don't know or should
we just keep going I mean yeah just keep
going all right hit play though this
it's rad she's training against like a
rock that looks semi like a person uh
Ray step a little
closer yeah there mean that's him there
on the right watching I want to see them
both like in sync doing that
right St yeah
exactly oh man yeah so what is that
what's going on it's so
cool it's like like uh have you guys
seen those oh my God those are walkers
in the background I didn't even see that
oh yeah so there is a walker scene this
was a big leak uh someone said that
there's going to be be a walker scene in
this movie oh it's not um they aren't
like that dust is being kicked up right
they're dragging something they're doing
they're dragging it you can see look
because when this one crashes it causes
dust that's red
yeah um so so by the way I I how much
you guys know or people who are watching
like there were Walkers like in the very
distance uh on that star killer base uh
just like in the for or the background
so these are
them but like this guy this guy's like
legit crashing like what the heck is
he's missing an engine oh okay or is he
no no no cuz the other wings look look
oh yeah it's like an
outrigger yeah like those boats that are
lopsided these things are
weird I love
it that's so
sick so it's like those surfboards where
you put the like thing under underneath
an hydroplane
right that's such a cool vehicle design
they look like they're going to fall
apart that's so
neat What's your deal can't read any of
that stuff
obiously uh sorry my button is not good
here yeah I mean that would that's like
the only shot of fin right there goes
his
wing and then yeah pose cool his second
X-Wing blows up sorry I'll play
this G I'm sorry my controls here are
awful uh so that so I imagine this is a
flashback right yeah because it looks
like the same scene where he puts his
hand on R2 in the first place right so
it's got to be more in depth of like the
Knights of Ren
right because uh that like flashback Ray
has that's the only really unexplained
shot is what's happening when he's doing
that
mhm his lightsaber clearly works
so it's not good wait go back to kylo
cuz he also gets cut on the face at the
end does he have a
scar yeah he does
uh that's not hair going across his eye
yeah
tight I'm sorry no one
truth more you think that's the same
shot or like those shots connect like
there's no way she was at the Jedi
Temple
right it's the shot of the Jedi Temple
and then it's the shot of a fasma in a
burning thing but that can't be the same
that's probably after the X-Wing blows
up or something yeah cuz right before
this is the also look at that there's
like that awing
is yeah it looks
modified yeah these these vehicles are
new too but they kind of look like the
medical frigs and stuff yeah what's that
thing in the background is that just a
blur or is that a weird
explosion oh it's just a
blast so we saw the Millennium Falcon
earlier who Pilots that now just Ray did
Tui take it for himself it's time for
the
Jedi to end I mean it's Ray
right I
mean I don't know who gives it to it's
got to be chew and then
cuz like if Ray's spending a lot of time
on that planet yeah I don't know it was
definitely in a fight so who flies it
I'm really curious about how Luke's
character is going to be after spending
so many years in isolation having lived
through so many things like he could
just be straight up like dire and like
super stoic he might be a little
demented could be that'd be super
interesting we just pointed out like
that I mean that line at the end is a
huge deal it's right but it might not
even be indicative of I mean I guess it
could be the very beginning where he
doesn't want a trainer right because of
what happened at the Jedi Temple and
then eventually he gets over it yeah um
but also like it's kind of this new
generation thing where it's like kylo
Ren isn't a Sith Lord he's a he's a
knight of Ren so maybe Ray won't be a
Jedi it's time for her to find her own
path or whatever right mhm mhm yeah and
then it is the Last Jedi but then again
I wouldn't be surprised if they went
with that plot and then the movie is
like no it is the
[Laughter]
Jedi I thought that was space at first
yeah that's they tricked me they got me
we were both right technically you said
the island I said space and kind of yeah
that was more right you were more oh
yeah you were
more it's crazy for such like these like
they can take any shot of an island so
they like get the perfect point and that
like blue and yellow
contrast
now reach
out that
is what are you
[Music]
saying
light
me
Darkness what is that
she says balance there
right it's so much
[Music]
bigger it sounds almost right that
pretty Rocky
yeah I only know one
truth
[Music]
it's time for the
Jedi to
[Music]
end man that that
uh sorry that walker scene is just
absolutely insane like what is the
situation here you
know I think
[Music]
one this is definitely like the
takeaway visual spectacle
yeah you know that's like Mad Max
inspired right just racing across the
desert it's like actually pretty similar
to the resistance like flying across the
lake and all that water getting kicked
up oh totally yeah it's really
cool uh did you guys say that excuse me
that this was uh these are books here
essentially it looks like that like a
few books like standing um in a
row oh my God and then also on the
island shots look for trees otherwise
they've got to be somewhere else
right I love seeing Force just used in
different ways you know what I mean like
breathe now a tree in sight
now reach
out what do you
say
[Music]
light that's
Darkness yeah it's like yeah a 10 books
books a Lord of the Rings Harry
Potter um someone mentioned that that
logo is like the logo of the Jedi Order
right but not much information you can
really get from
that balance well it was the the incinia
that was behind Luke in the original
poster remember he standing there with
the lights oh totally
[Music]
man you know what's weird about them
training together is they only have one
lightsaber as far as I
know oh you see an excuse me see an
awing there on the
left
yeah lot of Cloud City Vibe there I I
only know one
[Music]
truth it's time for the
Jedi so safe bet there's not going to be
a
battle why do you say that cuz I could
see you know kylo Ren and Ray doing
their own thing for entire film like
bulking up for the final
confrontation in the next movie perhaps
they're going to yeah they're going to
use them maybe not versus each other
though that like that's what I meant
yeah Ray running seems pretty intense
it's like there's almost nothing you can
glean from it but she's like sprinting
with her lightsaber out like it's like
the rocky three training Montage though
I feel like you know what I mean she's
just doing all everything she can to
like just power up cuz she's never had
to do that that didn't seem like
training no the one of her running at
night yeah sprinting dude I feel like no
I agree with Josh that seemed like she
was about to get into some that seemed
like someone she knew got hurt and she's
running after him or something uh see
you know all this this talk about like
you know there's light there's dark and
there's the balance between the two I
mean she could be learning what it means
to feel like anger you know to be scared
like all this stuff to feel frustrated
to be pushed to her limits I mean that's
what training is supposed to be like if
you're trying to like become some
[__] mythical Warrior I mean you gota
you got to like dig deep yeah it's like
uh during training not just in the
moment we never saw Luke go through any
of this yeah we did we saw him um have
the vision where he sees Darth Vader
kind of well sure but not the real like
rigorous training I mean right but that
doesn't seem like a training emotion
face does it not no I I mean I'm still
leaning toward yeah like why I mean why
else would this blade be out I don't
know like it it feels like some event
just happened and she's like chasing I
don't know but yeah I mean impossible to
say yeah it is uh that shot of all the
star Fighters um at the end space battle
confirmed
right that hasn't really been
one and a lot of this is I feel feel
like putting the light of like the
resistance being struggling you know
like this seems like a like a major
struggle for them you guys know those
like trash can bins that you like
wheel this kind of looks like those they
have what looks like Wheels you could
tilt that up and just roll it around
[Laughter]
damn I can't unse now it's kind of true
though yeah Finn was in the trailer but
just for like one shot where he still
hurt from episode 7
uh this looks like you know I wonder
what planet it's a gunner it's like I
was thinking they Gunner right here but
like the planet here I mean I wonder if
it's even like uh the planet that uh
Luke Skywalker and Ray are on which I
forget the name of maybe they're like
defending them or something yeah someone
made a good point in the chat when we
were watching it when she's swinging the
lightsaber at a distance I thought it
looked green so when she was running
with the blue one it was kind of like oh
different lightsabers but then I thought
oh maybe it's just color Distortion
because purple if anything what
that blue that's blue that's his saber
right it's yeah um I think it's blue
because she shows up with a saber that's
got to be all they have unless she
builds one
there that's blue for sure right also
what is she exactly
doing trying to hit that rock she's just
blindfolded he's just like yes he trying
to play breath of the wild blindfolded
this also feels like Revenge training
that he had with Yoda just like I'm G to
put you through some
[__] um yeah I don't know that we can't
really get any info from it but the shot
of the tree roots is pretty interesting
to me because I wonder where they are it
almost feels like they could have gone
to DEA for that also they look burnt
right so that would imply that like his
Jedi Temple was on fire so those are
probably you know the last things he
grabbed we leaving this is so cool in
this in this sense that it more I think
about is he's putting his his
infatuation with Vader to rest right
like the whole Mass steel yeah yeah his
character needs that yeah crazy to show
this during the trailer with like no
context and just be like shit's going to
go down with kylo
Ren uh so what didn't we see nothing
about snoke no
snoke uh that's it that's about it
no
Chewbacca C3PO who needs him I mean they
showed the back of uh layout right
that's going to be a weird one I don't
know how they're going to deal with that
she she finished shooting for this one
well they said they've got footage
they're going to use in episode 9 as
well oh really
yeah I could be totally wrong but I'm my
bet that that is Dea like they go there
or she does
there to get Yoda's books or something
so much yeah that would make sense cuz
the way that those like the material of
that tree looks is like very similar
like the swampy kind of Twisted like
roots and
stuff man so far in trailer history
after this Christmas is always like
strap
in this is so
[Music]
sick I only know one
truth it's time for the
Jedi to
end that's still really weird I don't
know what to make of
[Music]
it yeah what does he freaking mean by
that I don't know it's maybe the deal is
it's no longer about light versus dark
it's literally just about making sure
that like peace exists right so in order
to get away from this sort of dynamic
that keeps going it's just sort of find
that middle ground and just duke it out
and just doesn't matter who is good or
who is bad it just matters who wins
right wow because if look there's the
trailer yeah like if if she's sort of
like getting rid of the or if they're
getting rid of the Jedi together and
kylo ren is getting rid of Darth Vader's
like you know mask and all that dark
side you know related stuff that could
just be it it just there is no more dark
and
light yeah we'll
see that's pretty cool idea I mean it's
obviously the name of the movie is The
Last Jedi so right it's like one of the
central points about it yeah and you
know that's what's been he probably
realizes yeah that's that's what's been
going on for all these movies right is
just like this conflict that just it's a
cycle right so you got to end it somehow
he's defeated ending the cycle when uh
I'm glad that they're doing the
flashback sort of thing I know some
people are like H Star Wars doesn't
really have flashbacks but like the Jedi
Temple getting destroyed like needs to
be kind of uh I don't know examined a
little more rather than just something
that happened between
movies um so I'm glad they're doing
something with that yeah
uh you know they're yeah and they're
holding back this event right are those
statues on the
left yeah could be I mean so this is on
Gavin right so oh is it is that that's
where the temple is oh actually I'm not
100% sure I think that's just where it
always was in like the legend and
everything oh old lore but I guess
that's not known for sure anymore but
there's trees there too so maybe they
just went there I just feel like he went
on a hike and came back to
this
great tight cool I well I think that's
about all we can do for now I'm sure
uh as we said earlier like they're going
to break this thing down further and
further um um the best subreddit for
Star Wars stuff is Star Wars leaks
that's where all the like good
discussions happen yeah so um thank you
guys for uh sticking with us and you
know we did our best there looking at
that trailer uh that's really great I'm
excited uh this all actually worked out
and a little early uh which is fine
because we're uh we're beat and we
should probably uh end this um but yeah
thank you guys again uh you know
definitely feel free to leave comments
um on the trailer what you guys thought
and any uh theories you have do it and
uh Callie is down over at Star Wars
celebration she's going to get to see
something related to Battlefront 2 I
think so the few next few days we should
some new stuff to share on that as well
yeah definitely for uh Battlefront 2 so
stay tuned to uh Gamespot and uh we got
more on that thank you guys for coming
in thank you Eric Tay and John Luke for
uh helping put this all together uh that
was fun I had a great time um yeah thank
you guys for
watching yeah thanks guys all right
we're going to take off see you bye
[Music]
guys